Hi, I’m Evelyn From the Internets and I’m
here to talk to you about business.
I’m sure a lot of things just popped into
your head: Suits, meetings, skyscrapers, handshakes,
big cities, money, graphs, slide decks…
or the immediate UGH
when you think of “business”?
But we use business skills all the time.
Maybe you’re great at planning parties.
Or you’re always the peacemaker when your
roommates argue about dishes.
Or you’re basically a pro at making YouTube
videos that say something meaningful and
make people laugh.
Even though that just sounds like living your
life, all those skills can translate to
the workplace.
It's easier than you might think.
Plus, you know... kind of important.
Gotta pay those bills.
So, for the next 17 weeks, I’m gonna be
your host for the first half of Crash Course
Business, which is sponsored by Google.
We’re doing business too, you guys.
We’re gonna talk about Soft Skills, and
help you use what you’ve already got to
stand out and make moves in the business world.
Soft Skills is a kind of catch-all term for
buzzwords like Communication, Teamwork, Negotiations,
and Conflict Resolution.
We’ll cover big-picture ideas like leadership,
how to have a tough professional conversation,
and how to take care of yourself.
Because everyone’s talking about burnout
these days, and you can be good at business
and set boundaries.
And we’ll also give you plenty of concrete
tips about resume writing, interviewing, and
how to turn your lofty dreams into achievable
goals.
We’re here to help you hone your day-to-day
business skills, look for a job, get along
with your coworkers, and really take your
career to the next level.
Even if that next level is just getting started.
But, don’t worry, we’re not going to turn
you into a corporate robot.
Companies will want to hire YOU, not just
some weird carbon copy of what someone thinks
an employee should look and act like.
We’ll kick off the course with an episode
about trust, because it’s the key to working
with people and building your reputation as
both an employee and as a manager.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets, this is Crash
Course Business: Soft Skills, and I’ll see
you next week.